[Music]
on february 25th 1942 at about 2 30 in
the morning the people of los angeles
were jolted awake by the sound of air
raid sirens the city was ordered to
black out and prepare for an attack
search lights sprang to life frantically
scanning the sky above the city for
enemy aircraft finally the lights
converged on a single object as
frightened citizens stepped out of their
homes to get a glimpse of the target the
sky erupted with hundreds of explosions
of fire smoke and steel the battle of
los angeles had begun
[Music]
after the december 7th attack on pearl
harbor the entire west coast of the
united states was on edge henry stimson
the secretary of war warned that
american cities should be prepared for
attacks from enemy forces blackouts and
nightly curfews were common from alaska
all the way to san diego and rumors
circulated about japanese battle groups
invading the coast and of enemy spies
infiltrating the local population in the
early morning of february 23rd just
weeks after the pearl harbor attack the
japanese submarine i-17 stalked off the
coast of santa barbara it quickly
surfaced fired 25 explosive shells at an
oil field then slipped back beneath the
sea though the physical damage was minor
the psychological message was clear
america's coast was vulnerable to any
attack at any time the word went out
from u.s military intelligence west
coast city should brace for an attack
within the next eight to twelve hours
the entire la area was put on high alert
and early the following day just after 1
30 in the morning a radar station picked
up a strange object in the sky over the
pacific about 200 miles from la by 2 am
two other radar stations confirmed the
object now only 120 miles off the coast
it was big moving fast and headed
directly for the city by 3 am the object
which was now reported as about 25
planes at 12 000 feet was just off the
coast of santa monica only a few miles
from downtown l.a the city was ordered
to black out anti-aircraft batteries
were spun up manned loaded and told to
shoot on sight then suddenly the object
vanished from radar it disappeared well
from radar yes but visual sightings were
coming in from all over the city some
people reported seeing one large ship
others saw multiple aircraft flying in
formation at about 3 15 am the 37th
coast artillery brigade saw six planes
and for the next hour anti-aircraft
explosions lit up the sky as shrapnel
rained on the city below sightings
continued to come in the large object
had turned south and eventually
disappeared over long beach at 4 14 am
all clear was sounded and a few hours
later the blackout order was lifted when
the sun came up and the smoke cleared
over 1400 high-explosive artillery
shells and countless 50 caliber rounds
had been fired several people on the
ground had been killed in car accidents
or died of heart attacks from the stress
of the barrage but there was no evidence
of any downed aircraft no bombs had been
dropped the only damage was from
friendly fire so civilians and military
personnel alike were asking
what were we shooting at
[Music]
in the 80 years since the battle of los
angeles la has been one of the busiest
hot spots in the world for ufo sightings
and some of these reports come from
highly credible experienced military
sources and these sightings are covered
in project blue book the air force
program that investigated over 12 000
ufos between 1952 and 1969 and project
blue book was able to identify the vast
majority of the sightings as birds
clouds
right out of the 12 000 cases there is
still 701 unsolved unexplained objects
that have been documented in project
bluebook of the 700 cases the object
over la in 1942 remains unexplained
i am here to discuss the so-called
flying saucers
we have received and analyzed between
one and two thousand reports we've been
able to explain them as
hoaxes as erroneously identified
friendly aircraft as meteorological or
electronic phenomena or as light
aberrations
however there have been a certain
percentage of this volume of reports
that have been made by credible
observers
of relatively incredible things
we can say that the recent sightings are
in no way connected
with any secret development by any
agency of the united states
a japanese air attack was the most
logical explanation
even though 250 anti-aircraft guns
filled the sky with explosions and
shrapnel there were no confirmed hits or
downed targets after the war the
japanese military claimed they had no
aircraft in the area at that time just
the one sub a local police officer
claims he saw two planes shot down but
there was no evidence of that on the
ground secretary of the navy frank knox
said this was just a false alarm an
overreaction due to jitters but the army
disagreed they said the alert was
absolutely real the army report said as
many as 15 planes may have been involved
flying at various speeds and altitudes
the after action reports from the fourth
anti-aircraft command gives us a
timeline of what transpired that morning
at 2 43 am a gun officer reports
identified planes near long beach at 3
28 am battery g of the 78th coastal
artillery reports at least 25 heavy
bombers in the area and at 3 33 am 15
planes are spotted there are 37 separate
military reports including one from a
colonel all saw something over la during
this time if this event was nothing more
than jitters why are there so many
eyewitness reports of something in the
sky and how does that explain three
separate radar hits radar tracked an
object for 45 minutes for over 100 miles
so what was it well let's look at the
clues
[Music]
major keyhole what is your opinion of
these new sightings of unidentified
objects with all due respect to the air
force i believe that some of them will
prove to be of interplanetary origin
during a three-year investigation i
found that many police have described
objects of substance and high speed one
case polish reported their plane was
buffeted by an object which passed them
at 500 miles an hour obviously this was
a solid object that i believe was from
outer space
supporters of the ufo theory say the
radar hits are absolute proof of a ufo
but remember this is 1942 radar
technology wasn't perfect a world war ii
radar system could be thrown off by
weather birds or any number of naturally
occurring phenomena in fact one of the
three radar operators reported the
target as being doubtful there's a 70
page report in project blue book of a
ufo spotted just south of la a few years
later it was tracked on radar for eight
hours and seen by 30 people helicopters
and jets were dispatched to track it but
there was nothing there the official
report is radar was confused by the
weather and eyewitness accounts were due
to people's overreactive imaginations
skeptics say this is what happened in
1942. dirty people imagine the same
thing that's the report ufo makes more
sense i can't disagree but what about
the famous photograph of the object over
la this photo is printed in the la times
we can clearly see the searchlights
converging on something in the sky which
is in the shape of a saucer or football
but it turns out this photo was enhanced
and possibly retouched now this isn't
necessarily scandalous it was very
common to enhance photos to make them
more visible in newsprint the photo was
definitely doctored but it wasn't faked
but the original photo is very different
than what was printed it's underexposed
and doesn't really show anything besides
the lights which look very faint and
there's no way to track the original
because the negative is gone the
negative that's in the la times photo
archives is not the original something
that's only recently been discovered
when investigators worked with the la
times to try to track down the original
they came to the conclusion that the
photo used in the la times isn't
actually a photo from an la times
photographer so where did it come from
nobody knows we can see that some of the
light beams go through the object but a
couple of the beams do stop if there was
nothing in the sky wouldn't we expect
the light to continue into the distance
so if there's an object there why wasn't
it shot down by the ordinance that was
in the air that night well some people
say it was shot down and they claim they
can prove it
[Music]
the unidentified object moved slowly
down the pacific coast from santa monica
and disappeared south of long beach
several observers say they saw one or
more planes spotlighted by 20 or 30
searchlights shells frequently could be
seen bursting near the object but none
appeared to hit it approximately 20
minutes after the firing died down the
ship returned and headed westward from
long beach towards santa monica then the
ship disappeared for the second time
over the ocean
some military historians and
investigators researching the battle of
los angeles believed something was
definitely in the air that night and the
answer is in the official report the
report from the fourth anti-aircraft
command reveals that large weather
balloons were launched at 3am i can't
believe it i know
i know who's launching balloons in the
middle of a freaking attack now that's a
fair question but it was common practice
to check weather conditions in order to
assist anti-aircraft gunners with
targeting if there was a balloon over
los angeles it definitely would have
been spotted you had over 250 guns
pointed at the sky and there were over a
thousand civilian air raid wardens also
keeping watch they couldn't miss it so
the report claims when the commander
realized there was a weather balloon in
a hot zone he ordered it destroyed but
once the shooting starts people are
going to panic and there's going to be
more shooting
story hey that's the theory
then what about all the reports of
planes and bombers and what have you
well there's no explanation for those
there are also multiple reports of an
actual crashed aircraft in the middle of
the city and this was confirmed by the
lapd's 77th precinct so
what do they find
now it's one thing to be a tinfoil hat
claiming to see a crashed ufo
no offense
but it's another thing when there's an
actual police report about it but the
official government responses whatever
fell from the sky was likely shrapnel
and burnt embers from all the exploding
shells obviously the government had to
explain what happened especially with
this level of war paranoia but saying
this was an alien craft or even
admitting they didn't know what the
object was wasn't going to fly the late
dr robert wood believed there was a
cover-up he was an aerospace engineer
who worked for sikorsky hughes mcdonald
douglas and lockheed the usual suspects
yep after he retired dr wood researched
and exposed majestic 12 and other secret
government projects he was sent five
leaked documents about the battle of los
angeles and at least one of them has
been authenticated one of the documents
is a memo between fdr and george
marshall the army's chief of staff it's
dated one week after the incident the
memo says that two craft were shot down
one over the ocean and another over the
san bernardino mountains near la the
document reads this headquarters has
come to a determination that the mystery
airplanes are in fact not earthly and
according to secret intelligence sources
they are in all probability of
interplanetary origin well that settles
it aliens well not so fast the
government denies the memo that means
it's definitely true and dr wood
received photocopies not originals so
there's no way to test the paper or the
ink or authenticate them as genuine and
you really can't trust an anonymous
source and it doesn't stop the media
that's a good point still there's no
conclusive evidence and this case 80
years later remains unsolved
so if there was a flying object in the
skies above los angeles in february 1942
to this day it remains unidentified
[Music]
thanks so much for hanging out with me
today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment share that stuff
really helps out a small channel and
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you are appreciated
[Music]